[Music]
something I learned from improvising
really helps in communication there are
basic improvising techniques and
exercises like the mirror exercise where
you become my mirror and whatever I do
wherever I move you have to do that at
exactly the same time as if here is a
mirror with no lag time well if I'm the
person looking into the mirror and
you're my mirror how can you be my
mirror unless I help you be my mirror
I'm responsible for your being with me
in sync at every moment and it's a
wonderful image symbol of what
communication is because it's my job if
you don't understand it's my job to help
you understand and improvising each
improviser has the job of making the
other one look good you share the
experience right the principle of yes
and is an example of that it's an
improvising tool to use this idea of yes
and for instance we're in a scene
together and you look down and you say
whoa look at all that water down there
and I say that's not water that's the
floor well maybe I'll get a laugh out of
that from the audience but I've just
destroyed the scene and I've made you
look foolish
you called it water it's obviously a
floor that's yes it's not even yes it's
just no and you can say yes but and cut
it off with the but but if you say yes
and yeah look at that water let's jump
in and swim out to that whale and catch
on to the whale and swim away with the
web now I've accepted what you've given
me and I've added to it this is a really
valuable technique in communication to
not say to the person yes but you know
that's not true but there's something
about it that may be true maybe it's
under the surface the person is saying I
wish I understood how the universe
worked
and I think the unit
works like this we're all connected
psychically and we all have we're all
telepathic we can and you know and it
could go up into some place where you
don't really agree at all but the person
is trying to figure out things and you
can agree about that because nobody has
the final answer on anything I don't
think so you can say yes to that part of
it and you can explore some part of it
that you both can explore together but
the idea is if you cut off the
connection then communication stops and
it's your job to keep the other person
with you and the way you do that the way
you keep the other person with you is
keep reading the clues you're getting
from the person the person the person's
face the person's eyes the tone of voice
the body language the way they occupied
it share all of this all of these things
are clues to what's going on in their
head as you try to communicate with them
and the funny thing is I think I've
found that this works not only when
you're talking to them face to face it
also works when they're separated from
you by time and distance like when you
write something for them and you don't
know who's going to read it where or
when but you can figure out when you put
down the first sentence what that's done
to their mind where that where are they
now
so where is my next sentence going to
pick up on where they are now and take
them to the next place and if we don't
think about the person we're writing for
we're just formulating thoughts in our
head we're caring about ourselves
we're not caring about the other player
I think communication is a partnership
you have to think about your partner and
help your partner it's not me pouring
stuff into your empty brain first of all
you've got plenty of stuff in there
already that I'd want to know about
while I was writing this book I thought
not everybody is going to be able to go
to a improvising class and then I
started to think not only that I don't
go every
a couple of days to an improvising class
and this strange thing about empathy is
as valuable as it is we tend to lose it
it tends to evaporate it's very easy to
lose your touch in making contact with
other people I see it happening to me I
see it happening to other people so I
thought is there something I can do on
my own that would build empathy and keep
my my empathy thermometer at a high end
of temperature so I started
experimenting on myself I love to
experiment on myself and I thought okay
it has something to do with reading
emotions so why don't I as I walk down
the street as I go into a restaurant or
talk to friends why don't I try to
figure out what they're feeling and
maybe it'll be really good if I name the
feeling and I was talking to a
psychologist about this he said that's
this should you came up with this by
yourself I said yeah he said I'd like to
study back so he did a study where he
had people doing this during the day for
a week you gave them a standard empathy
test at the beginning of the week and at
the end of the week he gave him another
empathic test to see if their scores and
him empathy would go up by doing this
exercise and he had other things they
did to control variables and what was
interesting was not only did their
scores go up the more they did it so
that the people only did it twice didn't
go up very much but the people who did
it a hundred times during the week their
scores went up considerably not only
that it wasn't just naming the emotion
that they thought they saw on the other
person it was just noticing the other
person noticing noticing your hair
noticing your eyes what color your eyes
it's amazing how long I'll just think
about this the next time you're talking
to somebody how long do you talk to
somebody you just met before you really
notice what color their eyes are
shape is their is their eyebrow what
color clothing are they wearing if it's
a woman or a man what they are they
wearing jewelry what is it where did it
come from how are they sitting with what
am what clue am I getting from them we
don't notice one another nearly as much
as we think we do and those people who
notice the other people got higher
scores yet and empathy at the end of the
week and I found it's built up my
empathy at least I think it has but I
find myself much more comfortable with
other people I this is an amazing thing
I find other people less annoying it's
funny because I get a little more
empathy about what they're going through
what I think they're going through what
I can hear from things they say and
instead of being annoyed by them I think
I think I know where this is coming from
and it explains it and just getting the
explanation of what might otherwise be
annoying behavior or an annoying thing
they're saying if the annoyance kind of
evaporates it's not that empathy is
making me a better person it just gives
me a little more patience I find and I
think other people who have studied
empathy and found that there's more
patience associated with empathy so in
that regard it probably does make you a
little little easier to get along with
but I noticed when I get more empathic
my voice gets more intimate my face is
more welcoming and the funny thing is I
think I see that happening on the person
I'm talking to I think they're
responding to what's happening to me and
I'm getting from them a more relaxed
tone a more relaxed accepting visit it's
a good idea to monitor your own empathy
a little bit to be aware of the empathy
as you experience it I'll give you a
kind of a concrete example of this I
have a friend who went to a doctor with
a foot problem and he examined her and
he said oh my god you I think you've got
plantar fasciitis she got scared
she thought what is this an incurable
disease because you hadn't heard the
term before and it's a painful condition
and he had had the condition once so
when she figured out that she had this
condition he thought oh my god she's
going to feel terrible she might
experience her pain he was swamped with
her emotion he was swamped with her pain
and I interviewed someone in writing the
book who teaches scientists teaches
doctors to be empathic and one of the
things she teaches them is you have to
get inside the other person's head but
then you have to get out again you have
to manage your own empathy and you can't
be swamped with it it becomes what she
calls effective quicksand where you just
sink into the feeling because part of
the theory of empathy is that you
understand what the other person is
feeling because you feel it yourself you
recognize the feeling in yourself and
that gives you an understanding of what
they're going through but if you sink
into that feeling and get lost in it and
if it begins to rule you're into the
communication then it's no longer a tool
it's something that's working against
you you've got to have possession of
your own tools
[Music]